good morning millennials and welcome
back to the morning toast happy tuesday
and happy kickoff to our next couple of
weeks of maternity leave with guest
co-hosts and today's guest co-host our
first back in studio we haven't done an
episode in studio in 75 years is ben
soffer my husband also known as boy with
no job also known as the founder of the
greatest canned beverage to ever hit the
market spritz society hi ben hi darling
how are you i'm good how are you i'm
good i'm thinking that we should contact
ruby tuesdays and make them a permanent
sponsor of the tuesday episode why just
because they'd like come in they'd bring
us wings brought to you by rooms
no i don't even know what it is i assume
it's like a tgi fridays yeah i think
it's a regional thing because i've
actually never even seen a ruby tuesdays
in my vicinity i've seen a chili's and
applebee's at tgi fridays they're all
very similar i think yeah but no you're
really opening my eyes to the fact that
i've never eaten out of ruby tuesdays
yeah we should go yeah where do you
think they're most prominent i don't
know not here
not here definitely not here i've seen
i've seen one i think maybe in new
jersey that sounds about right you can
find almost anything in new jersey like
a sonic 100 true what is your favorite
like of those chains tgi fridays
applebee's chili's like what's your
favorite
hardcore
hardcore i hope we have the same answer
the bees a hundred percent
really applebee's is a neighborhood
place like it's such a gorgeous
institution it is it really is what do
you get there great diet coke
depends on like what i'm in the mood for
applebee's for lunch i would love to i
love the bees me too except i do believe
there's one in the city but applebee's
in the city is like not the vibe the
only thing that i'll say and i don't
know if this is the fault of airports or
if this is the fault of whoever owns and
controls applebees and chilies but like
these chilies to go
applebee's like those like janky
establishments that aren't real are
putting a horrific name on the
applebee's chili's franchises ben i
couldn't agree more but i will not let
you slander the good name of applebee's
because those are exclusively chili's
they don't have applebee's to go to
airports positive it's all chili's
really and i agree it's disgracing the
good name of chili's why do i have in my
head
it's like that that game where they show
you like two what's it called the
mandela effect yeah i promise you i've
seen applebee's have to go in an airport
stations at an airport no i've only
really seen chili's chili's chips yeah
okay but now i'm really hungry but do
you know the conspiracy theory around
that that they claim that we're living
in two parallel universes and sometimes
you dip into one and into another and
that's why you remember seeing
an extra marshmallow on this box and i
don't because we're living in different
effects in mandela effect because we're
living in different realities
simultaneously for those who don't know
the mandela effect i found out about it
on tick tock it's like you might have
this very distinct memory of like what
the fruit of the loom logo looks like
it's a cornucopia with lots of fruits in
it but actually in reality the fruit of
the loom logo doesn't have a cornucopia
on it but it's like the way we perceived
it so you say that the mandela effect is
due to parallel universe i just say it's
due to bad memory
but it's not bad memory if it's if
you're remembering more also i'm not
sure if it's the mandala effect or
mandela but i'm not just putting that
out there it's something with an m no
it's the same word but i don't know how
it's pronounced mandala or mandela
i think mandela like nelson was it his
no i don't think so
um so ben is joining me here for the
toast today we have five stories um of
varying
interests to you i tried to choose
stories that you could speak on we're
gonna talk a little bit about love is
blind but mostly because i know you have
a love is blind rant that you want to go
on is that correct not a rant just a
distaste for the show
by the way i couldn't agree more um and
we've got some acting news some space
news and i'm just excited that you're
here before we dive in how are you
i'm doing great i'm exhausted um
many might not know that while you were
on tour for three weeks i too was on
tour for three weeks different type of
tour
it was a spritz tour then coupled with a
me watching all of your shows which i
have to say is really really wonderful
it's available at girlsnowjob.com tour
yes i added another show in houston and
i'm playing the madison square garden
theater may 5th in new york city come
see me tickets available at girl without
dot com tour sorry to interrupt no
you're not interrupting the show is is
really unbelievable thanks unbelievable
and it's really nice to see like nobody
else will know this but like we know
some shows are better than others right
and when you get that amazing show it's
like [ __ ] yeah i have really enjoyed
having you on tour with me the last time
that we were i was on tour you were
in a position where you couldn't come
with me but now that spritz is the
sponsor of the tour we're doing all
these pop-up meet and greets at total
wines and bevmo's you and we're selling
spritz at most of the shows you have
been able to come with me and i have to
say it's been such a delight not only
because there's someone to help me carry
all my suitcases but also because i'm
not alone and i love having you yes it's
been great it really has been great are
you enjoying it yeah i'm loving it okay
good it's also just so cool to watch
people love spritz and love your show
and like if you guys didn't know claudia
finishes every show by chugging a
grapefruit spritz and it's just like
such a wonderful culmination of like
two years of beautiful work both on the
comedy and beverage side and it's it's
just really nice let me ask you
something um because i get asked all the
time about like which shows coming up
and for the most part we try to sell
spritz at every single show but at the
end of the day some elements are out of
our control if the venue has like a
legal um exclusive contract with a
certain other beverage like not it's not
like i was just did a show in atlanta
and we weren't able to sell it which
totally stunk which wasn't our fault so
coming up do you know which shows i'm
going to austin dallas in houston do you
know which shows we're going to be at
yeah we're we're selling at every texas
show great so i want to i want to
clarify because i got a lot of dms of
people saying why why aren't you selling
at the atlanta show i all that i wanted
to do was sell at the atlanta right it's
not even the venues it's you have to get
licenses for each state and we haven't
gotten our georgia license yet it's just
not it was not doable it wasn't doable
okay but texas we're going hard in texas
yeah and at the madison square garden
show i mean to be able to drink a spritz
at msg nuts nuts nuts what are you nuts
and very quickly before we digress if
you haven't been able to try it in
person and would like to try it online
have a wonderful exclusive offer go to
spritzsociety.com and use code toasters
t-o-a-s-t-e-r-s
the s at the end
gives you a month free it's buy two get
one three uh subscription for
subscription 33 off the steepest deal
really we offer did really well the last
time i was on the show people really
liked it it's good intro offer so
toasters with an s
buy two months get one three i'm sorry
to digress but can we talk about your
t-shirt yeah what does it say panic at
the costco where does one purchase a
t-shirt as awesome as that you literally
google panic at the costco and you get a
random man from the uk
uh who's gonna uh what what's that
called screen printum yeah yeah uh in
his house oh good um it's terrible
material like i probably have like like
babies or something scabies is life of
the body really scabies scabies or
scabies scabies it sounds like a pirate
term yeah it does scurvy scurvy yeah
scurvy yeah you probably have scabies so
make sure to burn that shirt before
you're ready
sickening i love a shirt with a message
yeah because what do you do at costco
panic i [ __ ] i just want to go on the
record and say i [ __ ] hate costco i
just want to go on the record and say
costco is literally the greatest place
on planet earth you can go there for
literally
90 beautiful baby croissants perfectly
packaged in a lovely lucite tin you know
what when we go for nine dollars when we
go on vacation and we stay in a home
with like a large pantry and a large
kitchen i'm excited by the idea of
costco i usually want other people to go
for me but i'm excited by the prospect
of the bulk items living in our
apartment now like
where are people who live in apartments
supposed to put all that toilet paper
costco is not made for us no it's not
that's it okay
costco is not made for us so we agree
costco is made for one with a large home
it's made for the ship beautiful pantry
it's made for the shapiro's the
shapiro's have everything from costco
the shapiro's literal like tvs their
toilet paper their light switches like
because they just renovated you can get
literally everything at costco their
daughter michaela was
was purchased at connecticut he was
conceived at costco they got so excited
her real name is kirkland
kirkland shapiro kirkland austria
shapiro that is so [ __ ] funny um okay
well thanks for sharing that with us of
course and is there anything else you
want to talk about before we dive into
the fast five
no i'm i'm very excited to be here and
i'm more than happy to come back anytime
i know you're we're going to need you
depending on jackie's availability so i
say that we dive in oh my god i never
get to do this part okay
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
why did you do that beat the crunch no
no we have a cruise i know that's my
game can i beat it
you don't remember that was that not
with you i wasn't here oh my game is can
you beat the cringe that is like
literally the most and i beat it
i know i beat it
if you listen back i beat it did we
still get the crunch on the soundboard
of course okay but i beat it you did i
know where did you go with that game
all right well before we dive in today's
episode is brought to you by turbo tax
people think unusual circumstances mean
complicated taxes but for turbo tax live
experts that's what makes things
interesting we all have unique lives
whether you're invested in crypto for
the first time this year you own an
up-and-coming small business or you're
raising rambunctious twins luckily turbo
tax live has experts who can answer your
tax questions walk you through the whole
process or do your taxes for you from
start to finish
they help you get every deduction you
deserve no matter your unique situation
and you can talk to a turbo tax live
expert through your phone or computer
without leaving your house turbo tax
live experts are here to help you
however you need and if you need an
extra hand hand your taxes off to them
and they'll do it all for you to turbo
tax live experts an interesting life can
mean an even greater refund visit
turbotax.com to learn more you do your
thing they've got your taxes intuit
turbotax live
tax season is upon us don't forget to
check out turbo tax live today's episode
is also brought to you by better help
relationships take work especially the
most important one you can have in your
life which is your relationship with
yourself and a lot of us will drop
anything to go help someone we care
about we'll grow out of our way to treat
other people well but how often do we
give ourselves the same treatment it's
so important to invest in yourself
whether that's therapy coaching any sort
of self-care and better help is a great
asset for that because this month better
help online therapy wants to remind you
that you matter just as much as everyone
else does and therapy is a great way to
make sure you show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours give it a try and see why
over 2 million people have used
betterhelp online therapy again this
podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and the morningtoast listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
toast that's b e t t e r h e l p
dot com slash toast um if you're going
through it or even if you're not going
through it any time is a good time to
start therapy whether you feel like
you're really in need of some guidance
or you just want to stay on the good
path that you're on and better help is a
great place to do that okay
fast five are you ready i am am i
sinking into this couch no you look
great i haven't changed positions at all
have you moved your microphone no but
it's much higher yeah okay you could be
adjusting i'm sinking sit up no but i'm
just saying like you could just move you
don't yeah good
okay ready
yes i'm ready sir all right big news in
the rock and roll industry dolly parton
responds to the rock and roll hall of
fame thanks but no thanks so dolly
parton has announced that she's pulling
out of this year's nominations for the
rock and roll hall of fame saying she
hasn't earned that right the music icon
who's been elected into the country
music hall of fame explained her
decision in a statement posted on her
official social media pages on monday
noting she didn't want to take votes
away from the remaining nominees here's
what she said
even though i'm extremely flattered and
grateful to be nominated for the rock
and roll hall of fame i do not feel that
i've earned the right i really do not
want votes to be split because of me so
i must respectfully bow out um she also
went on to say that like she would be
open to being nominated once she does a
rock and roll album which she wants to
do one day because her husband is like a
huge rock and roll guy but at this point
in time our humble queen has decided to
bow out wow yeah vowel friend bow wow
very respectable i know can you imagine
being like that
no no but it's so interesting like when
you told me this story this morning
i thought that maybe she didn't accept
it because like she was above awards no
no no she's not at all it's quite the
opposite she is so
uh
appreciative yeah but like
why would dolly parton be nominated for
she's like a country music icon why
would she be in the rock and roll hall
of fame because there are some people
who have been in the rock and roll hall
of fame um and the country hall of fame
brenda lee johnny cash elvis presley
chet atkins hank williams and the everly
brothers
i mean
and by the way the other people
nominated with dolly parton are eminem
lionel richie duran duran and a tribe
called quest
and the question was why is she even
nominated for rock and roll hall of fame
right and i guess there is
they probably are struggling like every
other dumb award right and need
more people to talk about the award so
it doesn't completely lose relevancy
that's true
which is why i thought you were gonna
say that she felt that she was above the
award that she didn't need it no she's a
humble queen like she doesn't
it's clear she's never done rock and
roll
so why the [ __ ] would she be in the rock
and roll hall of fame that's like me
being in the nfl honors like
it's a little different but it's very
similar like i've never played football
i guess that's true no i guess okay it
would be like
me being i don't know i can't think of a
comparison because like she does music
she just doesn't do rock and roll music
yeah
cool yeah it's fun
like we i stan uh a queen who knows her
place i really do yeah same and so now
out of the this uh nominees who do you
think should get in for rock and roll
yeah i was gonna say none of them are
rock and roll lionel richie's pretty
rock and roll no he's not r b no he's r
b lionel richie is an absolute king
though have you seen the music video
uh for hello
is he oh no no that's adele yeah
it's a wonderful song and a great music
video so em see i don't i guess i really
don't understand the criteria for who
gets into the rock and roll hall of fame
because these people eminem lionel
richie oh duran duran is a rock band
and i'm not familiar with a tribe called
quest uh also not a rock band
so
based on
this who do you
i mean
none
no i would say duran duran okay
is there a difference between the rock
and roll hall of fame and the hollywood
hall of fame because it sounds pretty
similar it's the hollywood walk of fame
and it's incredibly different
so the hollywood walk of fame you know
it's like the hollywood boulevard in l.a
hollywood boulevard it's the hollywood
boulevard um
walk of fame where like you get a plaque
on this on the street yeah for just
outstanding performance in entertainment
generally like eddie cohen just got one
you can get one for i think it's for
overall tv movies i don't think
musicians really uh
yeah no musicians get it it's overall
entertainment yeah snoopy i'm right i'm
just saying this also feels like overall
entertainment it feels random it feels
random for sure well um wishing dolly
the best and
we saw doc oh you weren't there i saw
dolly in vegas
she was um the hostess did you see her
in vegas yes she was the host of the acs
very cool um and she was just first of
all hosting an award show at any age is
so hard like it's three hours of
non-stop go go you sing you dance you
perform you talk you mc you have alpha
changes and she just did it with the
utmost elegance and grace and it was
really kind of sickening to be the same
building as dolly yeah dolly's great
dolly is everything i remember her as
hannah montana's aunt a godmother yes
godmother yeah i completely i love how
like that's how our generation was
introduced to dolly parton yep
hannah montana
i love that reference yeah we should
watch hannah montana yeah we should all
right next up is love is blind
um so the news is that shayna hurley
from love is blind is engaged
after the kyle split and it's not to
anyone from the show
um she's moving on the love is blind
star shayna hurley is engaged to her
boyfriend christo silardakis after
splitting from her netflix co-star kyle
according to people dowling reports that
shayna 32 accepted a proposal from
lardarkas ladarkas
larticus
on thursday and that the couple has
already made plans to tie the knot in
greece this summer shayna is engaged
she's been dating christos for almost a
year and this is the happiest i've ever
seen her an insider said he has stood by
her through all the love is blind drama
and has been her steady in the storm so
people are freaking out because like it
appears to them she just got engaged on
the show but this show was filmed a
while ago i'm sure it's been well over a
year since
the two were ever romantically involved
but um
i don't really care because like i'm so
over talking about these people and i
did want to give you a platform to tell
us how you really feel about love is
blind it's the dumbest show on tv do you
think this season was or just
conceptually the show is a dumb concept
this is the only season i've seen oh
okay because the first season was like
some of the best television i've ever
watched in my entire life cool
i literally watched one episode of this
season i was at the shapiro's and i told
them i will not watch any more of this
let's go to the finale yeah well then i
watched the finale so i can understand
what happens with these
looney tunes these people are nuts so i
did a patreon episode kind of recapping
the first five episodes when i was
really into it um and the overall
consensus that i came to was like so the
first season was so good and first of
all we got two married couples who are
still together this was like
right before covid so it's been a while
how many couples go on the show in
general well so
they have like tons of people do the
experiment and tons of people even get
engaged but the show only ends up
following certain people because either
the people who didn't end up getting
married were boring so of the of the
experiment just because i do have a
point here you said the first season
there are two couples that got married
stayed married so they classified that
as a successful
show how many people entered that room
to date probably 30 maybe more okay so i
wonder if you run statistics
i bet you're really blind no i bet you
one in 15 people if they get married
after three weeks stay together 115.
i mean like i guess i get what you're
saying but i'm not so concerned as the
experiment more than i'm concerned about
just like entertainment value and that
first season was so good got it okay and
me and jackie were recapping and we
think why it was so good is because you
know we're used to watching tv shows
like the bachelor where people just go
on and they're just looking for fame
they're looking for instagram followers
they're not really looking for love and
they're all just like
insanely good looking like to a point
where it's just not realistic and with
love is blind it's like we just got
normal people who looked normal who
acted normal they weren't overly thirsty
they weren't ready to start youtube
channels like they were just
normal people
and that i think was part of the reason
why the show you're saying that's the
first season the first season got it
because that nothing you just said
described this season in my opinion so
now the second season
i felt like the people they casted were
so
before i saw them acting on social media
afterwards like just when i was watching
the show i was like yes these people are
so normal to the point that they are so
unbelievably boring like they are like
lifeless and i and i thought that the
greatest thing about the show was now
working against the show they casted
people who were too normal but now
they're all on social media like acting
a fool i can't okay so i don't even know
if you know this so it is rumored that
kyle who was engaged to shayna
is now dating deeps
deep teeth i i remember okay
what do you think about that
i think that it again it's very very
hard to really tell it seems like deep
tea really did go on that show with good
intentions looking for love even though
i'm sorry
why why would you go on a show looking
for love if you really want love don't
go on a show yeah no i agree but like
ben we're very blessed like it is hard
to meet someone these days you know it's
much harder to meet them on a reality
show i don't disagree it's much easier
to meet them through friends or at a bar
or on tinder yeah it just if you're
really looking for love that's the thing
that's flawed with all of this like just
acknowledge that people are this is a
great plot for a show you want to become
uh you want to get hundreds of thousands
of followers on instagram you want to be
in the public eye and you have a chance
you know maybe you'll like someone there
that's a good plot what's the plot the
plot is just partying and having a good
time which is what these shows are
anyway
getting people overly drunk that's love
island great so love island makes sense
yeah love island's a great show except
why is it called love island because
they're honorable it should be called
influencer island no but they're
literally on an island and they're all
like hooking up yeah but it's not love
uh there have been many couples shannon
and josh who graced that couch it could
end up being love but that's like the
goal of the show that's not the goal no
it is
it's not though no no it's literally the
goal of the show okay
it's a good show
um so congrats to shayna on her
engagement i will probably not be
keeping up with love his mind anymore
like the season just really was such a
time waster like who did shayna
originally like
shane oh
brutal brutal just nuts honestly and
like actually i don't even want to talk
about it it'll set him off set him off
shane he'll find it
he's the guy was really really crazy
yeah and then the girl that he was
dating natalie was equally as crazy and
like mean they were just mismatched
terrible honestly like i just couldn't
watch the show but so they were
mismatched but the entire time they're
standing on the altar talking about
i can't believe i'm bringing up with my
best friend
you met three weeks ago how are you best
friends it doesn't make any sense that's
the whole thing everyone i've grown
you're my best friend you're my
everything my i can't believe it like i
can't believe how close we've gotten
like what you spent half the show in a
box talking to each other and then two
weeks in person and you got like engaged
and your best friends like these people
are so reckless then i couldn't agree
more but you're my best friend dude yeah
of course after 10 years
no it's a good point like the best
friend thing is like so
they all say it though because they
don't know what else to put in their
fake ass vows because how are you
supposed to have vows about somebody you
just met
ben has literally become unhinged isn't
that true no by the way i couldn't agree
where they all say the same [ __ ] it's so
boring and like you oh also
getting married at that brothel where
they just [ __ ]
[ __ ] people in and out in the same
exact room
that's gross yeah it's [ __ ] up oh deep
tea you're done now it's time for shane
yeah come on in guys my best friend love
you
it's sick then you are being so funny oh
my god
it's sick i agree and it's it was really
like a waste of my time and i feel like
that's an unpopular opinion because
people are like
dying like kyle and dt were spotted
together like people are just like
gagging like i could not care less yeah
they were spotted together because this
entire media paparazzi news cycle is
begging you
begging you to have uh just go back to
it and keep your attention on the show
and talk about it yeah oh my god so fake
and manufactured and stupid ben that was
like top five one of my favorite moments
ever with you thank you so much for
bringing joy to millions of toasters
including but not limited to kylie
jenner i
i told ben
um i'm sorry that's not nature okay i
just want to say it was nature
and then there was a nail and then there
was a message
that jackie and i received
can't say from who
can't say from what
but it was
it was pretty much a confirmation of
what we had believed i forgot i got the
dm this morning really yeah i mean you
could sneak something else in
like yeah no but i'm we're gonna ask
kylie for another sign when jackie's
back on monday because we don't know for
a fact that kylie tunes into the guest
co-host episodes like maybe she's a
ride-or-die og jack and claude stan it's
possible so we're gonna wait till monday
to ask for another sign um
but just know like you are listening to
a podcast that like
kylie jenner most likely listens to and
that should make you feel good going
about your day
um before we dive in um i'm really
excited about the next sponsor because
it's purple which is the brand of my
smelly pillow and you have been on the
journey with smelly pillow in me and the
toasters have been on the journey too
and if you're not convinced to switch to
purple
then just wait because i'm about to
change your life
there are all these gimmicks that pop
promise a great night's sleep but i
don't care about what kind of toppers
you have how heavy your blanket is it's
all a lipstick on a pig if you're
sleeping on a terrible mattress you will
sleep horrible and it's just that simple
that's why we recommend the sleeping
that's why we recommend sleeping on a
purple mattress because purple's only
only purple mattresses have the gel flex
grid which is the exact material that's
in my smelly pillow and what makes it so
smelly special
um it's really like a unique it's just a
material i have never felt in my life
before and i didn't know good sleep
until i was introduced to the brand
purple i'm being dead serious
and you could try a purple mattress
risk-free with free shipping and returns
and they also offer financing which is
great it's super okay so the purple
squishy material which i just lived to
sniff
is super stretchy ultra squishy material
it adapts and flexes around pressure
points and it doesn't retain any heat so
if you're a warm sleeper like we tend to
be um purple is going to be the mattress
for you they have great shipping it's
really easy they're super customer
friendly and their website's really easy
to navigate getting a great night's
sleep starts with having a great
mattress and get a purple mattress
when you go to purple.com
tmt as in the morning toast and you use
the code tmt so purple.com slash tmt
code tmt for a limited time you can get
10 off any order of 200 or more that's
purple.com tmt code tmt for 10 off any
order of 200 or more purple.com tmt
promo code tmt terms apply um
let's be honest have you kind of felt
threatened in the bedroom by smelly
pillow
you definitely love it and i would say
that it is your adult stuffed animal
that you sleep with a hundred percent
you have the same type of
need for smelly pillow as i did for a
teddy bear when i was nine ha don't lie
nine how
old but then i lost it i left it in the
cab oh my god you're lying it was the
saddest day of my life i left a
sleepover
left him in the cab did you were you in
the cab by yourself
i think so maybe i was 13. you were
loving it by yourself maybe i was 13.
then don't lie how old were you when you
used a teddy bear 17
no no no this was in middle school but
whenever it was the end maybe 12 13.
that's a little bit because you were
taking a cabbage blue and beautiful oh
yeah i'm sorry he's gone now well that's
what you have for being irresponsible
totally it's the consequences of your
honor i shouldn't take him anywhere i
should have left them at home 100 like
something that important should never
leave the house i also would you have
been that kid at a sleepover like crying
calling your mom like mom i can't sleep
without my smelly pillow no okay i just
wouldn't i would tell her to pick me up
were you that's not i can't sleep were
you that kid who like occasionally would
need to get picked up yeah
from sleepovers really unless i had if i
had my blue bear
and i had my
honeywell fan
[Laughter]
you brought your own fan to sleepovers
every single sleepover in my life are
you being serious yes and if i didn't
have it i couldn't sleep honey why
because of the the cold cold and
love like a sound
machine asleep oh my god you are lying i
would show up with a fan and a bear you
would pack up your things at your house
be like mom let's leave in five and you
would just throw a fan into your duffel
bring my fan
and my bear how big was this fan was it
about like no you don't know like a
boxer
box fan would be bigger than me yeah no
like you know like those bigger than you
when you were 12 no it's true same size
you know those uh honeywell fans that
have a stand
like they're flat
no it's not like a big it's
so it's a box fan no it's like it's like
this big
and it has like a stand and then a neck
with the circle
it doesn't have a neck the honeywell's
only tilted up and down so it has a neck
because it moves up and down no a neck
would imply that you can go like this
what does your neck do just this
no your neck goes like this ben you're
being so funny today no but thank you no
that's a good call no the honey the
honeywell fan has like it's a tilt a
tilt yeah that's what i meant that's not
a knack okay you know what i meant okay
do you understand the fan i'm talking
about i can't believe you used to bring
fans to a sleepover like you were so
funny yeah it was great yeah
that's cool cool um okay well sorry
there's still more stories
okay done with love his mind let's which
we go next oh some heartbreaking news
sandra bullock is taking a break from
acting
so sandra bullock has a new movie coming
out but
she's planning on stepping back from
acting while promoting her film lost
city which co-stars channing tatum and
brad pitt sandra bullock told
entertainment tonight that she's not
sure how long she'll of a break she'll
be taking but she said she does know
that she wants to be in the place that
makes her the most happy she says i take
my job very seriously when i'm at work
and i just want to be 24 7 with my
babies and my family that's where i'm
going to be for a while
sandra bullock is a mother to louis 12
and layla 10. um she
what does she have planned with her kids
she plans on servicing their every need
including their social calendar
um okay so sandra bullock is taking a
break and i just like would love to be
in a place in my life where i could just
like decide to stop working for like a
few months you know you did
when paternity leave when you weren't
pregnant excuse me i'm running a
business and we
value family leave something you
wouldn't know anything about okay value
family leave certainly totally by the
way like let it be known that for three
out of four of the maternity weeks i was
working you were on tour totally [ __ ]
okay okay i'm just kidding okay sorry
[ __ ]
um
so yeah cinderella's taking a break from
acting how do you think that's gonna
shake up the hollywood industry it just
sounds a lot like tom brady like yeah
i'm retiring big headlines i'm back
what i think about tom brady unretiring
i'm thrilled by it because he's amazing
and he shouldn't have retired i also
think that the fact that he never
thanked the patriots yeah in his
retirement speech was really [ __ ] up
because he's the greatest player of all
time
because
of the patriots everything that happened
with the patriots patriots drafted him
him and bill belichick him and his great
receivers
right the most recent
of his
uh sort of accolades was with the bucks
his life of becoming a hall of famer was
the patriot so i think
this gives him a second chance to come
back
maybe win another championship
and do it right like so my thoughts were
that tom brady should have retired the
first season after the bucks like he
just yeah
went out with like a bang a super bowl
win he proved like he didn't need the
patriots like he loved it but he
couldn't he was still the greatest of
all time no matter what team you went to
so now do you think he's waiting to win
before retiring
it's possible because don't you want to
you don't want to go out a loser if you
have a legacy and he's so competitive
right yeah did you hear about the guy
that paid 555 thousand dollars did you
guys talk with us already no but can you
explain it to me so
after tom brady
retired there's obviously the last
touchdown that he'll ever throw
and the guy bought that ball at an
auction for half a million dollars
but it's no longer the last touchdown
ball he'll ever throw so the guy spent
half a million dollars on he gets [ __ ]
he gets
[ __ ] you're kidding no i mean this is
a very very rare circumstance right or
actually it used to be it's becoming
less rare
right because [ __ ] is just changing now
athletes are now like doing like encores
and like pretending that they're not
going to come back out on stage and then
they do gronk
did it uh
who else did it tom brady did it there
are way more that have done it
whatever i'm blanking but no i know
people come out of retirement
fairly often these days got it okay i
thought you were gonna say
do you remember the guy in the stands
who like caught
tom brady's last touchdown ball and then
they took it away from him and gave him
a bunch of crypto yeah and then tom
brady was like actually can i have that
back because we need to like auction it
and what did they give him
they gave him like a bitcoin which at
the time was worth 70 grand is now worth
39 000.
bitcoin is crashing it's not crashing
but it's fluctuating it's it's on the
lower end uh right now okay um
what else do they give him other like
sign [ __ ] but nothing is valuable but
now now i bet he's happy because that
ball isn't that the ball i don't know
that's what i was asking if that was the
ball he should be thrilled yeah because
he just got no actually now it's funny
you can spin things like now the ball is
the controversy ball and like i'm sure
it's still worth a lot of money because
it's the ball that was supposed to be
the touchdown that isn't the touchdown
and collectors just go nuts for serious
one-of-one things like that yeah so i'm
sure it still holds value but not near i
don't think it should be
but it doesn't hold as much value as
sandra bullock taking a break from
acting no i didn't even know she was
still acting yeah me neither what was
the last thing oh she was in that
congeniality no she was in that netflix
movie that everyone died for bird box
where like they were all covering their
eyes but i never watched it because i
don't like scary movies i didn't see it
the last movie i think so the last thing
i saw sandra bullock in oh ocean's 45 or
whichever lady she was also in space
recently
you mean space the movie no
have come out in 2016. okay i'll tell
you hold on
i think it was called gravity sandra
bullock movie about space was it 2016
it was called gravity and it was
2013. oh yeah oh
no life is so long but it's so short oh
my god that's crazy
i never saw it though me neither
was it good oh you didn't see it me
neither
um
so yeah i just think that like a
hollywood will never be the same yeah
totally actors and actresses take
themselves very seriously i know it's
like that's why i can't watch the oscars
i'm like these people are so out of
touch very seriously but also like again
probably just her publicist and team
actually taking their jobs too seriously
yes i'm sure sandra bullock didn't come
out and say guys we need to run press
about me leaving hollywood you know what
the last line in this article from cnn
entertainment says lost city hits
theaters on march 25th yeah it's like
promo for the movie but can i tell you
how crazy like i went looking for
stories this morning on every single
website this sandra bullock story was at
the top when it's like not even breaking
news no we're on the pr team
um
okay
our last two stories are pete and kim
skeet skeet but they're separately and
they're not really about the kanye stuff
but if you do have any thoughts you're
more than willing more than um welcome
to jump in but this story is about kim
kardashian's brand skims they are
debuting in inclusive skims swim line
featuring innovative separates and one
one-piece suits so kim kardashian's
empire is expanding the beauty and
fashion mogul41 announced on twitter and
instagram that her ultra popular brand
skims will be dropping its first
swimwear line this friday they posted a
series of photos including photos of
herself modeling the new looks in the
water and on the shore
so they
obviously they're just swimsuits there's
bikinis there's one pieces there's
cutouts there's also like very kim like
like biker shorts and a tank top that
are now bathing suits
are they going to be in the color of
like nudes no they're blue they're gray
they're colorful there's no they're not
like beyond bright and colorful but
they're muted colors like very skims
brand um i saw a bunch of influencers of
all different sizes and shapes getting
them on tick tock and they all had rave
reviews like saying the material was so
great the colors were so great the fit
was so great of course skims has gotten
to be a three billion dollar company i
think mostly because they're incredibly
size inclusive and the bathing suits are
going to be no different so while this
isn't like life-changing news i did
think it was really interesting because
not too long ago kylie dropped kylie
swim it's still in her instagram bio as
her
list of businesses but it did get like
kind of roasted online for you know the
material being kind of see-through and
just like not being the greatest quality
and i always wonder
when kardashian brands like
converge like kkw beauty and kylie
cosmetics like where
where's the competition you know so i
don't know if kylie swim is like still
going to be a thing because she did one
drop and then like we haven't really
heard from her um
and it appears as though this skim's
swim is going to be extremely successful
like i'm calling it
what do you think
how many more followers does kylie have
than kim great question i'll tell you
right now
kim has
it's so crazy that kylie has more kim
has
292 holy [ __ ] and kylie has
318 so that's like 25. that's like an
entire
another a-list actor
in terms of reach right so what i'm
trying to say is that
you said the reason why skims are so
successful is because they're so
inclusive
like sorry no that's not true no it's
definitely a night it's really nice and
every brand should be inclusive so that
i could go to paul smith and get a
[ __ ] t-shirt instead of being this
now right right it's a nice thing but
i'm saying having that many followers
doesn't guarantee a successful business
no having that many followers though
with a great product
right does guarantee something yes and
so like kylie has 318 million followers
she launched kylie swim and i think it
would generally be considered a flop the
brand hasn't posted on instagram since
october 2021. so i wasn't saying if it's
a flop or not i was just saying that you
said in terms of competing businesses
then both going into swim or
makeup or whatever i'm saying that kylie
has an extra 40 million people that she
could talk to that maybe
25
27 okay so maybe it's a bad call no like
i just think and this is the thing with
the kardashians that people never like
to give them credit for it's like yeah
they're the most famous people in the
world of course they're going to be rich
but like they have achieved like
levels of successful business that are
just beyond schemes is worth three
billion dollars
kkw beauty sold for a billion dollars
kylie cosmetics was valued with coat
cody whatever at a billion dollars like
that just doesn't happen because you're
famous like it's another level yeah
of success and like business yeah and
they surround themselves with really
smart business minds too no but they're
all why do you have to say that would
you say that about a man of course i
would there's i forget her name there's
there's somebody that i found on
instagram that it looks like she runs
all of their businesses
tracy romulus
emma
from shark tank
no oh maybe yeah what's her name emma
what emma greened or
greed yeah i think yes yeah yes she was
just on shark tank by the way so she was
like the initial investor in good
american she launched good america with
chloe and now i believe she's involved
in skim she's like this gorgeous queen
and she was just on shark tank and i
like fell in love with her i just
started following her on instagram too
she was so good on shark tank like
really valuable insights i think you
would enjoy the episode yeah i hope she
does another one i'm not taking anything
away from them by the way it means a lot
to also assemble a great team i agree
like i just think it was weird that was
the first thing you said oh god
ben hates women
yep that's me how does your sister and
your mom and your wife feel about that
interesting yeah interesting i'll
remember i remember yeah you should i'll
remember so uh remember skim swim is
coming i actually feel like i might be
purchasing
some swim i trust skims is just a great
brand can you believe they're valued at
three billion dollars yes you can
believe it yes i think it's so crazy
sell out of everything yeah they
uh to your point have a great product i
felt the material on the usa collab
jammies yeah my favorite great material
yeah
and they've just
captured drop culture like nobody can
that was like like also the kylie lip
kits that was so back in the day like i
remember in college like literally being
on kylie lipkids.com like refreshing
refreshing refreshing and i think one of
my greatest claim to fame is i was able
to get like two out of three of the og
kylie lip kits amazing yeah those were
the days
um okay well we still have one more
story it's about pete davidson and it's
brought to you by noom you can sign up
for your trial and get psychology-based
support and motivation to reach your
goals at noom.com toast that's n o o m
dot com slash toast to sign up for your
trial so unlike other restrictive diets
or workout programs new weight uses
psychology to empower you with the
practical knowledge and skills you need
to build smarter more sustainable
long-term habits and behaviors noom
doesn't believe in restricting what you
can or can't eat instead noom gives you
the knowledge and wisdom you need to
make informed choices that not only fit
your lifestyle but also help you reach
your goals more than 75 of users have
completed the program and more than 60
of users
lose 5 or more body weight by 16 weeks
and more than 60 percent of users
engaged with the program keep the weight
off for a year or more so there's so
many things to love about new especially
the food tracker they have a food
database which makes it really easy to
just visualize and see what you're
eating but it's also like the most
expensive sometimes if you're ever
trying to like use random apps to track
your food it's just like super limited
they are known for having one of the
largest and most expensive food
databases um and it makes it really easy
to just like keep up and
keep track of what you're putting in
your body start building better habits
for healthier long-term results sign up
for your trial at noom.com toast that's
n-o-o-m.com
toast
it's the final story it's the final
story
ready
pete davidson
and five paying customers are going to
fly on jeff bezos's suborbital rocket
into space cool so pete davidson will
become the latest celebrity to fly to
space with jeff bezos's rocket company
blue origin and a brief sub-orbital
flight slated for later this month the
company announced monday morning that
davidson the saturday night live star
who's become a pillar of entertainment
intrigue amid his relationship with kim
kardashian will fly alongside five
paying customers on blue origin 60 foot
tall new shepard rocket the launch is
slated for march 23rd at 8 30 a.m
central time
and the announcement comes after cnn
confirmed earlier that davidson was in
talks with the company for a seat aboard
its supersonic rocket which launches
vertically from a rural texas launch pad
on bezos's ranch um okay would you ever
go to space
yeah yeah yeah do you think there's a
chance like of you dying
no
like if you got the opportunity like i
don't think i would want you to go i
would definitely go i think i would too
yeah
but like would you pay like
no i think right i think what's
embarrassing about this is like the five
paying customers and how much like give
the money to charity like you obviously
have too much it's a lot because i think
me and jackie were talking about it one
of these like it's not like a full trip
to space where you're like in a rocket
you just it's like 20 minutes like you
go up and down it's a supersonic that's
what all these celebrities richard
branson they're all doing that
and in order to do one successful
supersonic trip i think it costs like
250 000
so your tickets need to be equal to 250.
so what's 250 divided by five
it's 50 grand
that's not that there's no way yeah no
it's a lot no that might be a little
yeah no i think it's probably more than
that there's no way that it's 50 years
but that's what it costs jeff bezos 250
grand
it's a great business model for him
right he gets to send people to space
there's no way he's charging anything
less than a quarter of a million dollars
that's insane money like people are so
wasteful yeah but one time if you're
really loaded you want to go up peak at
space it's kind of cool yeah i guess
again kim is going to be waiting down
probably at the ranch for pete actually
no
like if she wanted to go she could go
right no or maybe she just wants to
witness it interesting do you think
they're cute like what's your vibe
um i love pete davidson i've always
thought he was hysterical and like
literally the only reason why snl is
still on tv is because pete davidson and
keenan thompson have carried the [ __ ]
show on their back mckinnon and kate
mckinnon and kate mckinnon yep and
what's her name actually
chloe fireman no
no eddie bryant yes yeah i agree love
her yeah but
pete
um it's i think part of the reason why
snl has remained like firmly
in popular culture and his roasts are so
good like he's always he's now like a
pillar like the roast
jeff ross jeff ross i can't remember
anybody's names let's say bob ross
he's a pillar like jeff ross of these
roasts and they're just so good
um so the question was what do you think
about them as a couple i know you got
off track no i was getting there okay no
i was just really god i was being
helpful i swear i was not being a [ __ ]
um
i think that it's like
a little weird but the relationship why
i i don't know i don't age i'm not sure
what don't you like about it let's talk
it through because you're wrong so i
want to get you to the right side i
don't know no i i don't think that it's
weird now i think that it just felt
weird then but i guess maybe it felt
weird because it definitely felt random
but like not really like
pete is known for dating the most
eligible women in hollywood and kim just
became a single eligible woman i guess
that that's the piece though that like
in just such a superficial hollywood it
just is a little bit strange
to me
like i love the idea of all of these
people valuing humor over everything
else right because you're saying he's
not conventionally good he's not
conventionally good looking and he's not
conventionally rich and it is well not
compared to there's just no there are
just things that you
are used to superficial hollywood
thought holding value in and pete has
broken down those barriers yeah no
question he has yeah we love that no we
do i'm just saying it seemed strange in
the beginning now it seems lovely yeah
um
but i'm a big fan of pete's i'm just
saying that it's uh it doesn't sound
like you're a big fan of it no i am it
seems like you are literally with
pitchforks no because like i really
think that this is the best relationship
of all time like when they break up i
will be so sad no it is but you need to
definitely
admit that it was a very different and
shocking choice
for kim for kim why
i don't know why the hell would she be
with chris humphries
because he's an nba player because he's
good looking and because he's rich
i think name everything he said is more
rich and chris humphries that's just a
lie really yeah humphrey's good it
doesn't matter he's an nba player that
probably made a hundred million dollars
even it's like a really successful
comedian he's on snl he has
um
done a lot of movies like
they're not even close how much money
okay that's a good question how much
money do you think pete davidson has
like the pete davidson today i guarantee
you he has more money today than he's
had the rest of his career and i bet you
that his net worth is literally a
million dollars all right let's see i
don't think you're right how much money
his net worth is eight million dollars
and by the way i bet you that went up
seven since he started dating chris
humphrey is
not worth i don't know why we're
comparing chris humphrey by the way not
net worth career earnings oh okay
because his net worth was really high
okay totally career earnings i didn't
know that was a thing
oh my gosh and now i want to go through
every single day and now i want to go
through every single person
and now i want to go through every
single person that kim has dated why
because this is important i'm right what
are you right about what's the point i'm
not understanding the point is that the
reason why it was a strange choice is
because based on her historical
preference of men she's it must be 10
years based on her historical preference
of men including her current her husband
so reggie bush okay chris humphreys
reggie bush money
looks fame
yeah humphreys money looks fame pete
money looks famous you want a different
skin no kanye money looks fame the most
famous person ever
but now kim is the most famous woman on
the planet she doesn't need i understand
which is why she chose uh to pick
somebody that she really liked which i
value and i think it's great i'm not
sure like what your message is here but
i think we are agreeing what my message
here is is that the original choice
caught me off guard because i typically
know kim's relationships at least from a
bird's eye
to be rather superficial yeah no by the
way and this one seems to have come from
a place of
love
okay
i agree
you
coming for me with a pitchfork i just
really wasn't understanding what you
were saying and i'm still not like 100
sure what you were saying but i know
that i love you and i agree with you i
don't you know what i'm saying
every single person that kim started
dating was rich good-looking and famous
so she started dating pete and he was
i'm sorry he's good-looking and famous
you think he's having a good looking guy
in a unique way for sure okay
yeah i just wanna let you know like the
general consensus like from popular
culture is like p davidson is hot
okay in a different way okay that's fine
not as hot as you obviously no by the
way i i don't care i just
he's not
good looking by the standards of this
hollywood regime
not the regime he doesn't look like them
100 i just feel like you're twisting my
words i'm really just sitting here
you're twisting my words i think we
should just put a put a fork in it you
know
i'm very happy for them those were the
fast five stories ben thank you so much
for joining us is there anything else
you want to just chit chat about or are
we free to go
no we're free to go just again
code toasters with an s
t-o-a-s-t-e-r-s
buy two months get the third free and a
glorious subscription shows up once a
month beautiful box beautiful experience
and
and now an award-winning cocktail i
don't know if we've mentioned that i
don't think we have we are award-winning
the grapefruit won an award at the san
francisco wine festival which is
extremely prestigious maybe you haven't
heard of it but it's a real wino thing
to know you know and all of the
cocktails rated a 95 out of 100 on pure
wow they are just wow unbelievable wow
we we made them because taste matters
and life's too short for drinks you
don't love so they're literally the best
thing like i don't know what i drink
like what i was drinking before but
garbage garbage like it's this or
tequila like that's it that's it and you
mix this with together when i'm at a
party or something that doesn't have
spritz like i feel it like i'm like
addicted not addicted i'm like obsessed
with spreads yeah they're the best so
yeah code toasters with an s buy two
months get the third free in a glorious
subscription ben you're the best thank
you so much for being here thank you
darling you will of course be back yes i
will um but until then toasters tomorrow
who's oh taylor striker's on the show
tomorrow that'll be fun and easy she's
just a pro just like you
um and until then have a great day thank
you so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennial morning show where
we deliver the fastback stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio ihop radio
cast box all the places so ever listen
to the podcast by now this morning just
leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are hope
you guys have an amazing day ben i love
you love you and you want to say
something to toasters like bye
bye